This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一档来自I-Heart的播客。保证是由真人录制。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难学训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个节目主要探讨黑人男性的生活经历，进行一些在其他任何地方说出来都不安全的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人像穿着盔甲一样生活？它向世界释放出一种信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须得这么做，快来“艰难学训”节目中寻找答案吧。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
你可以在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《艰难学训》。在2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的检测结果很多次，对吗？我伪造过一次检测。这动用了大批网络侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男性：格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我当时惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷情网》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《深陷情网》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he does. He's going to get what he
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在 我们这个奇特现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的 人。请在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的。他会得到
deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another December guest episode. And today we're bringing on someone who is not just amazing, but is also a pretty close friend and a podcaster, half of the true broke chicks. We have our. Thank you so much for coming on the show.
应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。请在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《相信好姐妹，相信我，宝贝》（Trust the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在二十岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听友们，老听友们，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，回来收听另一期十二月份的嘉宾节目。今天我们请来了一位不仅非常了不起，而且还是相当亲密的朋友兼播客同行，她是播客“真实破产辣妹”（true broke chicks）的半边天。我们有请——。非常感谢你来参加节目。
What an intro. Thank you. You're welcome. Flushing. thank yes I don't know why I'm so I don't know why I feel so awkward doing this considering that this is not even our first this is like our third episode that we've ever done like together either on your show or my show and then we also like we talk all the time and we have an office space together and yet it's like I'm sitting here it's because we're professional talking yeah I guess so I feel like it's like we need it like more yeah it's professional we're being professional and it's like because we have an audience yeah whereas most of the time when we're just talking We're just talking smack.
好一个开场白。谢谢。不客气。脸红了。谢谢。我不知道为什么我这么，我不知道为什么我感觉这么尴尬，考虑到这甚至不是我们第一次，这大概是我们俩一起录的第三期节目了，不管是去你的节目还是我的节目，而且我们平时总是在聊天，还在同一个办公空间办公，然而我就坐在这里，是因为我们是专业说话的人，对吧？我想是的。我觉得这就像是我们需要，对，就像是这很专业，我们在表现得很专业，而且是因为我们有观众，对吧？然而平时我们聊天的时候，我们只是在胡扯。
Yeah. But it's always smart smack. I'm not going to lie. Like sometimes we'll be like debriefing in the office and we'll give each other advice. I'm like, that's good stuff. Yeah, that is. I'm like, I'm like, we need to write that down. I'm actually, honestly, I honestly, I've like stolen things that you've said to me and put them
对。但说实话，那总是聪明的胡扯。我不会撒谎的。有时候我们在办公室里复盘，然后我们会互相给建议，我会觉得，这干得漂亮。对，确实如此。我说，我就觉得，我们需要把它记下来。老实说，我真的，老实说，我甚至偷用过你对我说过的话，然后把它们
on the podcast because I'm not that wise all the time, right? No one is. Yeah. I need the wisdom to come from an outside source. I've done the exact same. I've been listening to like your podcast. I'm like, actually good. tip. Yeah. Okay. I'm going to use it. I'm going to repurpose. Yeah. Which honestly is great because I do
放到了播客里，因为我不可能一直都那么睿智，对吧？没人能一直这样。对。我需要智慧来自外部的源头。我完全做过同样的事。我听了你的播客，然后我想，这建议其实真不错。对。好吧。我要用它。我要重新包装一下。对，说实话，这挺棒的，因为我也
also feel like, so you guys talk a lot about like your 20s obviously, but also like the intersections with like money and like, you know, certain like social and like cultural phenomena and changes that are happening. But the big focus is on like finance and like managing your money or your expectations around money and your like relationships better. In our 20s. And a big part of that that I think is really important to discuss as we're like entering into the holiday season. But really at all times and just coming out of Black Friday, Cyber Monday, is impulse shopping. Yeah.
觉得，所以你们俩显然经常谈论二十岁的生活，但同时也探讨了它与金钱的交集，你知道的，还有某些正在发生的社会和文化现象及变化。但主要的焦点还是在理财上，比如如何管理你的金钱，或者你对金钱的期望，以及如何更好地处理你在
Impulse shopping is a huge one because I think in our 20s for the first time we're like making like adult money. And we can like kind of start to afford the things that as children and as teenagers we needed to ask our parents for or they were kind of like luxuries. and if you've never like learned to budget or have that like proper financial literacy, your spending can get like quite out of control. Yeah. Like, and I so I really want to focus on that like the ways that we use like impulse shopping, retail therapy, overspending to like self-soothe. I feel like you, have you had experiences with this?
二十岁时的关系。而其中很大一部分，我认为在我们进入假日季时讨论非常重要，但其实在任何时候都很重要，而且刚过完黑色星期五和网络星期一，那就是冲动购物。对。冲动购物是一个巨大的问题，因为我认为在我们二十岁的时候，我们第一次赚到了“成年人的钱”，我们可以开始负担起那些我们在还是儿童和青少年时需要向父母索要，或者被他们视为奢侈品的东西。如果你从来没有学会如何做预算，或者缺乏适当的财务素养，你的消费就会变得相当失控。对。就像，所以我真的很想关注这一点，也就是我们如何通过冲动购物、零售疗法、过度消费来达到自我安慰的目的。我觉得你，你经历过这种情况吗？
You know I have. I know. I was setting it up. I didn't want to be like, tell me about. Set me up. No, good, good, good. I like it. I like it.
你知道我经历过。我懂。我是故意抛出这个话题的。我可不想表现得好像在说，来跟我讲讲吧。抛出引子。不，很好，很好，很好。我喜欢。我喜欢。
No, it's true because even with, you know, we've been doing. who broke chicks for two years. And we kind of started very general. Like we were in a lot of niches, which we still are. But I think it's gone to show how much we kind of need to open up the conversation around shopping, spending and money with, you know, how much our audience has wanted that in the last year especially. I think what on what you were saying as well, unless you've learned how to budget and spend, like you're not going to be very good with your money because you don't know how. But you're also not taught so it's up to you to self teach like yourself because not a lot of us have had parents that you know sat us down and was like this is how much you save or they did and then once we move out
不，这确实是真的，因为哪怕是在我们开始做“真实破产辣妹”两年以来也是如此。我们一开始的定位很宽泛。我们在很多细分领域都有涉猎，现在依然如此。但我觉得这表明，尤其是在过去的一年里，随着我们受众的需求，我们多么需要敞开关于购物、消费和金钱的对话。我认为就像你刚才说的，除非你学会了如何做预算和花钱，否则你不会很擅长理财，因为你根本不知道怎么做。但你也没有被教导过这些，所以这取决于你自己去自学，因为我们当中没有多少人的父母会坐下来对你说，这是你应该存多少钱，或者他们教了，但一旦我们搬出去，
and we don't have that adult influence and we are the adult we don't really know how to do it and it becomes really overwhelming and then I think with impulse shopping and Christmas season there's like two ways to think about it because you're either spending for you're yourself and you're like, oh, do you know who would like that? Me. Or you're shopping for other people. And so there's two things that I like to think about when I'm thinking about impulse shopping, especially at Christmas time.
身边没有了那种成人的影响，而我们自己成了成年人，我们其实并不知道该怎么做，这就变得让人极其不知所措。然后我觉得说到冲动购物和圣诞季，其实有两种思考方式，因为要么你是为自己花钱，然后你会想，哦，你知道谁会喜欢那个吗？我。或者你是在为别人购物。所以当我考虑冲动购物时，尤其是在圣诞节的时候，我有两个想法。
And the first one is that you can't buy your own validation. Like you can't buy self-confidence. You can't buy like you then magically thinking that you're like the hottest shit in the whole entire world. So whenever you're like, oh, I've got to go. out this weekend, I need to buy something. That's not going to fix it because there's going to be another weekend. And that I think that insecurity is never going to be dulled by something that you buy online. It does, does help in the moment. I'm not going to lie. Because I do that all the time.
第一点就是，你无法买到自我认可。就像你无法买到自信。你无法买到那种让你觉得自己仿佛是整个地球上最辣、最火的女王的神奇幻觉。所以每当你想着，哦，我这个周末得出去，我需要买点东西。这根本解决不了问题，因为还会有下一个周末。而且我认为，那些不安全感永远不会因为你在网上买的东西而得到缓解。不过说实话，那一刻确实有点帮助。我不会撒谎的。因为我一直都在这么做。
I'm like, I have this event. I don't feel like I have anything that I feel hot into wear and I would buy something. And then it's just this like toxic cycle. And on the other hand, with other people, because we have like enough money to spend we kind of want to seek and buy their love or admiration or maybe you get a bit competitive with siblings at Christmas time that you want to get like the best present or do you do you remember that episode of the office did you ever watch the office? I did. Yeah. I know exactly which one. And Michael buys the iPod. Yeah and he's like you can point to this dollar value and be like I love you this much. I digrained in my brain. Exactly. But I think and And again, I myself have had this in the past where I buy people so much stuff because I think
我觉得我有这个活动，我觉得自己没有什么穿起来让我感觉很辣的衣服，然后我就会买点东西。接着这就变成了一个有毒的循环。而在另一方面，对于其他人来说，因为我们有足够的钱花，我们就会倾向于去购买他们的爱或崇拜，或者有时候你在圣诞节时会对兄弟姐妹产生一点竞争心理，想要买到最好的礼物，或者，你还记得《办公室》（The Office）那一集吗？你看过《办公室》吗？我看过。对。我知道你说的是哪一集。迈克尔买那个iPod的时候。对，他就像是你可以指着这个美元价值说，我这么爱你的。这已经深深烙印在我的脑海里。完全正确。但我觉得，而且再次强调，我自己过去也有过这样的经历，我会给别人买很多东西，因为我认为
that's how I can tell them that I love them and that that will make them love me too, which is a love language. But gift giving is not the highest price tag that you can spend on someone. Gift giving is like the thought that if, you know, they really like cooking, you could make them a rub, like a meat rub thing. Oh, a meaty rub. I don't really cook a lot with me. So that came out of nowhere.
这就是我告诉他们我爱他们的方式，并且这会让他们也爱我，这是一种爱的语言。但送礼并不意味着要在某人身上花最高的价格。送礼就像是那份心意，如果，你知道他们真的很喜欢烹饪，你可以给他们做一个干料擦剂，比如肉类擦剂。哦，肉类干擦剂！我其实不怎么用肉做饭。所以这话有点莫名其妙。
That was actually pretty good. Look, like a cookie dough, okay, you know, paprika, you could make them their own, like, yeah, you go to the local, like, go to the local, like, paper or, like, office supply store and make them like a cookbook of, like, the favorite recipes that they've ever made to. Exactly. Or, like, even a photo frame with a nice photo of it. Yeah.
那个其实还挺不错的。你看，就像饼干面团一样，好吧，你知道的，红椒粉，你可以为他们亲手制作，对，你可以去当地的，比如去当地的文具店或办公用品店，给他们做一本他们曾经做过的最喜欢的食谱的书。完全正确。或者甚至是一个相框，里面放上一张美好的照片。对。
In there. And I think, as well, what I do each year now is I, like, haven't listed my phone of a notes app and it's, like, got the budget per person. and then I plan out every gift. Like before I buy it and then I go find that gift. So it's like I'm not just like shopping around. I don't just go on to like the David Jones website open gifts for him and then just start scrolling.
放在里面。而且我觉得，我现在的做法是，我每年都会在手机备忘录里列个清单，上面写着每个人的预算，然后我会规划好每一份礼物。在购买之前就规划好，然后再去找那件礼物。这样我就不是在漫无目的地闲逛了。我不会随便打开David Jones网站，去点“男士礼物”然后开始往下刷。
Yes, that's dangerous. Is going to hurt. Yeah. And I think it's, it is going to hurt, especially when you're doing it for like five, six, seven people. And it's so interesting because I think Christmas is,
是的，那太危险了。会大出血的。对。而且我觉得这确实会大出血，尤其是当你需要给五、六、七个人准备礼物的时候。很有趣的是，我认为圣诞节，
or like the holidays when we're recording this is obviously like a big time when our budgets just like go out the window because there's such an expectation to shop to shop big there is very subtle ways that every company in this world is trying to convince you to spend more money right now but then i think so it's kind of more understandable during the holiday season but i think impulse shopping during like the every like everyday life also comes down to a lot of like a lot of what it means to be like in the in-group so in the sense of like buying trendy clothes to kind of like perform for other people is something that I think especially in our 20s we have to be wary of and part of the influence of that is social media it like it really creates
或者在我们录制节目时的这个假日季，显然是一个让我们的预算彻底泡汤的重要时期，因为大家有着强烈的购物和大手大脚消费的期望。世界上每一个公司都在用非常微妙的方式试图说服你现在多花点钱，但与此同时，我认为，虽然在假日季期间这还算情有可原，但我觉得日常生活中的冲动购物，其实也归结于很多关于融入圈子的渴望——也就是说，为了向别人表演而购买潮流服装，我认为这恰恰是我们二十岁时必须警惕的事情。而这种影响的一部分来源就是社交媒体，它真的创造了
like a entire like psychological system of like social comparison yeah well we've spoken about this like the amount of times I've been like I hate my clothes yeah and I feel great in them but it's because I'm constantly scrolling and seeing people who are super fashionable. And so I buy in order to make myself not just feel better, but to like almost suppress the sense of like. Yeah. It's like acceptance because we're all humans and we're so scared of rejection that it's like even words like Chuggy that started trending.
一套完整的心理机制，也就是社会比较机制。是的，我们谈论过这个，我讨厌自己衣服的次数简直数不清，对。虽然我穿着它们感觉很棒，但那是因为我一直在刷手机，看到那些超级时尚的人。所以我买东西不仅是为了让自己感觉更好，甚至是为了压抑那种……对。就像是对被接纳的渴望，因为我们都是人类，我们太害怕被拒绝了，以至于像最近开始流行的“Chughey”这样的词。
Chuguey, I don't. Chugie was like this thing and it was like, I think Gen Z came up with it. I don't know. But it was like, Chugie is like cringe. So if you do these things, cringe or if you wear these things now they're cringe and it would be like just pieces of clothing that used to be trending but now they're chugy oh okay and it was like the and you know what business is probably froth this shit because it means that their quick tone over is just going to make them more
Chugie，我不。Chugie是这样一个词，大概是Z世代创造的吧？我不知道。但意思就是说，Chugie就像是老土、尴尬（cringe）。所以如果你做了这些事，就很尴尬；或者如果你现在穿这些衣服，它们就很老土。它指的是那些曾经流行过、但现在已经过时的服装。哦，好吧。这简直就像是，你知道商家绝对乐疯了，因为这意味着消费者快速淘汰产品会让他们赚到
and more money of like being able to sell you more and more stuff um which is why I love the development of a capsule wardrobe by the way oh I was just about to say it's really interesting because I think like each year. You did an episode on this, which I really would actually recommend people go and listen to called Women Are Not Trends, which is amazing. Oh my God, I could talk about this phase. Exactly. And it's so links to things like overspending retail therapy, Impulse Shopping, because especially like women are taught that like every like six months there is a new definition of the it girl. There is a new definition of like what is hot. And each of those versions comes with a different outfit, comes with a different makeup look, comes with different accessories.
越来越多的钱，他们能够向你兜售越来越多的东西。这也是为什么我很喜欢“胶囊衣橱”（capsule wardrobe）这个概念的发展，顺便说一句。哦，我正想说这个。这真的很有趣，因为我觉得每一年。你之前做过一期关于这个的节目，我真的强烈建议大家去听听，叫做《女性不是潮流》（Women Are Not Trends），太棒了。天哪，我可以聊这个阶段聊一整天。完全正确。这与过度消费、零售疗法和冲动购物紧密相连，因为女性被灌输的一种观念是，每隔六个月就会有一个“It girl”（当红女孩）的新定义。就会有一种关于什么是时髦的新定义。而每一个版本都伴随着不同的服装、不同的妆容、不同的配饰。
Yeah. Whether it's like clean girl or like messy girl. I love my shit at to me. Tomato Girl. Tomato Girl was when I like put my foot down and I think I had a full blown tantrum in the podcast studio that day because I was like, this is fucked. Oh, what is it? I actually, I remember listening to this. Isn't it like the kind of ready makeup and like, no. So that's strawberry girl makeup. Oh, that's strawberry girl. So tomato girl was like the Europe girl, which again, it's all marketing because this, this tomato girl trend came out when every Australian except me went to Europe. I was also in the same. It was actually kind of rude. I felt like I was back in high school and I was like guys can I sit with you and they said no we're in Europe.
无论是“干净女孩”（clean girl）还是“凌乱女孩”（messy girl）。我最爱我那套了。西红柿女孩（Tomato Girl）。西红柿女孩风出现的时候，我真的是忍无可忍，我记得那天我在播客录音室里发了一通超级大的脾气，因为我觉得这太荒谬了。哦，那是什么风格？其实，我记得我听过这期节目。那是不是那种带有红色妆容的，不对。那是“草莓女孩”（strawberry girl）妆容。哦，那是草莓女孩。所以西红柿女孩风是指那种欧洲女孩风，话说回来，这全都是营销，因为这个西红柿女孩的潮流出现时，除了我之外，所有的澳大利亚人都去了欧洲。我也在那个地方。这其实有点粗鲁。我感觉自己回到了高中，当时我就想：“伙计们，我可以和你们坐在一起吗？”他们说：“不行，我们在欧洲。”
But it was like the girl who wears a headscarf with linen and takes her book to the park. I'm like so you're wearing linen and you're reading a book like it's just it's and it's hot. Of course you're going to wear linen. Everyone wears linen when it's hot. So it's just these things that they invent, like you said, the it girl. And we then have to kind of fit the mold because there is definitely certain criteria to all of these trending girls, which is just yuck. Like it's just, and it is to convince you to be like, oh, you want to be a vanilla girl? You have to go buyugs and you have to go buy a cream Stanley cup.
但这种风格就是穿着亚麻头巾、戴着亚麻制品、带着书去公园的女孩。我就想：所以你就是穿着亚麻衣服在读一本书，这很热。天气热的时候当然会穿亚麻。所以这全都是他们虚构出来的东西，就像你刚才说的“It girl”。然后我们就不得不去迎合那个模版，因为所有这些潮流女孩背后显然都有着某种特定的标准，这真的是太令人无语了。这简直，就是为了说服你觉得：“哦，你想当一个香草女孩（vanilla girl）吗？那你必须去买Ugg靴，还得去买一个奶油色的斯坦利保温杯（Stanley cup）。”
And all the items that are, you know, in that stencil of this woman are all very expensive items as well. Yeah. And then look at Frank Green. Like everyone's talking about Stanley Cups now. Yeah. Whereas last year and Yeties, whereas last year everyone was frothing Frank Green.
而且，你知道的，符合这种女性审美的所有单品全都是非常昂贵的商品。对。然后看看弗兰克·格林（Frank Green）保温杯。现在每个人都在谈论斯坦利保温杯。对。然而去年大家都在狂热追捧Yeti保温杯，再前年则是骆驼水壶（CamelBak）。每年都是如此。所以，人们感到有必要购买商品来填补他们身份认同的一部分，而这部分正是人们 constamment 要求他们去改变的，这也就不奇怪了。如果你落后了，
And the year before it was like camelbacks. Yeah. Like every year. Yeah. So it's no wonder that people feel the need to kind of purchase items as a way to kind of fill a part of their identity that people are constantly asking them to change. And that if you're like behind,
你就会被叫作“Chuggy”。所以你会想要去适应，去迎合那些不仅在社交媒体上、而且在你日常生活中不断向你展示的东西。我认为我们真正需要讨论的另一个因素是，公司和品牌是如何制造出一种“损失厌恶”（loss aversion）心理的。
you're going to get called Shuggy. Like you want to adapt to like, like what is being shown to you, not just on social media, but in your like, just like everyday environment as well. The other factor that I think we really need to talk about is how, like, how companies, how brands create a sense of loss aversion.
所以我觉得很多人都有冲动消费的问题，他们往往把这归咎于自我纪律的问题，而不是去看到他们其实生活在一个特定的语境中——生活在我们当下这个不断鼓励你通过制造潮流、It girl或社交媒体以及社会比较来购买东西的现代社会里，同时也是通过许多非常精妙的手段——我必须给它们记上一功——也就是那些操纵你的认知工具。比如告诉你某些东西快要卖光了。我其实挺喜欢听你这么说的，真的。对，我想让你告诉我。好吧。
So I think a lot of people have problems with impulse spending and they see it as a self-discipline problem rather than the fact that they live in, within a context, within like a current modern day that is. constantly encouraging you to buy things either through like the creation of trends or it girls or social media and social comparison but also through things like a lot of these really amazing I will give them credit like cognitive tools that manipulate you so telling some things are going to sell out I like that from you actually yeah I want you to tell me yeah okay so there's
其实有一个我记不清了的词，是品牌们会用的，类似于“年终消费者”什么的？然后他们会讨论这种人，因为基本上到了年底，我们就开始不在乎钱了，然后就会想：“管它呢，明年再说吧。”我们基本上会放纵自己的消费冲动。然后我们不停地买买买，结果自己陷入了一个大坑。我们就会想：“你知道吗，我明年再从坑里爬出来好了。”我们把所有东西都放到先买后付（Afterpay）上，然后想着：“我明年再还清。”
actually a word that I can't remember that brands use it's like an end of year consumer right And so they discuss this person because basically we're at the end of the year and we kind of stop caring about money and then we go, I'll just deal with it next year. We kind of like, you know, let our inhibitions go with our spending. And we just spend and spend and spend and we kind of get ourselves in a whole. And we're like, do you know what, I'll just dig myself out of it next year. We put everything on afterpay and then we're like, I'll pay it off next year.
这就好像是“那是留给明年的问题”，但实际上，这明明是现在的问题。所以品牌和营销人员会采取一些手段来劝说这种年终消费者花钱。其中之一就是限时闪购（flash sale）。比如任何限时一小时五折的活动，尤其是当网页上还有倒计时的时候。这样你就会觉得，天哪，因为这是一种害怕错过的心理（FOMO）。这是一种害怕错过划算交易的恐惧，也是一种对你可能根本不知道自己是否想要的商品的炫耀心理。如果你——我是说，如果你知道自己过去六个月一直想要一台戴森冷暖空气净化器，但你一直在等一个好折扣。
It's like that's a problem for next year where it's like, no, it's a problem for now. And so there are a couple things that brands and marketers do to kind of convince this end of year consumer to spend their money. One is a flash sale. So anything that's like 50% off one hour only, especially when they've got like a countdown on the site. So that you, you know, you think, oh my God, because it's this fear of missing out. It's a fear of missing out on a good deal and that bragging rights of an item that you probably didn't even know that you wanted. Like if you, and I say, if you know that you've wanted, you know, a Dyson hot cool air purifier for the last six months, but you've really been waiting for a good sale.
然后那个折扣真的来了，而且限时一小时，当然了。那你就去买吧。你知道自己想要那个东西。但如果你只是因为看到促销，去买了一双粉红色蛇纹西部牛仔靴——说实话，听起来我好像挺喜欢的。我知道。我感觉自己会疯狂心动。但如果我买它们只是因为我看到了那个促销，那我大概根本不需要它们。我甚至不知道自己想要这东西。
And that sale happens and it's an hour only, sure. Like, sure, go by that. You know you wanted that. But if you're, like, buying a pair of pink snake skin cowboy boots, which honestly, like, I sound like I would love that. I know. Like, I'm like smash. But if I'm only buying them just because I've seen that sale, I probably don't need them. Like I didn't know that I wanted that.
所以，是的，正是这种紧迫感真正启动了你的购物和消费冲动。而它所做的一切，就是迫使你打开促销页面。然后你就会继续往下刷。一旦你到了那里，就会遇到第二个策略，那就是“消费满额即可免运费”。所以我们都爱吉尔玛（Gilma）。但如果你需要花50美元才能省下5美元的运费，你最后只会买一堆根本不需要的垃圾。就像我说的，如果你是在The Iconic网站上买圣诞礼物，而且你可以在一个地方把多个人的礼物一次性买齐，那真是惊艳、完美、勇敢，
So yeah, it's this this sense of urgency that really kickstarts you into shopping and spending money. And what it does is it forces you to open up the sales section. And then you're going to keep scrolling. And when you're there, it's the second tactic, which is spend this to get free shipping. And so we all love Gilma. But if you need to spend $50 to get free shipping, which was $5, you're going to just end up buying crap. don't need. Like if, again, if you're doing a Christmas shopping on like the iconic and you can do, you know, a bunch of shopping in one place and it's for multiple people, stunning, amazing, brave,
我太爱了。但如果你只是因为觉得自己“必须找点东西凑够免运费”，而那甚至都不是送给任何人的礼物。我做过这种事。哦，我们都做过。我一直都在这么做，然后我还会克制自己，心想：“等等。”而且你太容易陷入那种多巴胺带来的快感中了。对。因为这真的很有趣。很有趣。购物很有趣。
love that. But if you're just shopping because you're like, I've got to find something to get free shipping and it's not even a gift for anyone. I've done this. It's, oh, we've all done it. I do it all the time and I still check myself and I'm like, wait. And it's so easy to just get wrapped up in the dopamine hit of it. Yeah. Because it is fun. It's fun. It's fun. to shop. And also you feel like you're saving money. Like that is the the appeal of the sales section is in your mind and there is there is actually a term for this and I've completely forgotten it. But basically your brain is doing like the calculation of what this could have cost you if you bought it three weeks ago such that actually now you're up because you're buying it three weeks later at a
而且你还会觉得自己省了钱。这就是促销专区吸引人的地方，在你的脑海里——其实这有个专有名词，但我完全忘光了。基本上，你的大脑正在计算：如果你三周前买下它，它本来要花多少钱；而现在由于你晚了三周才买，并且享受了折扣，实际上你反而是赚了。这让我想起了赌博。就像是——我该怎么做才能……当我们有了赌博机制，或者那种能从某事中获得不确定奖励、多巴胺，或者从购买中获得“我赢了”的感觉的机制时，这在许多方面都会强行重塑你的大脑，让你做出可能并不符合你最大利益的决定。就像我很喜欢你刚才举的那个例子：如果你确实有一段时间非常渴望某样东西，那利用促销去买是很好的。但我也觉得，就像你刚才说的闪购，它为我们提供了
discount. That's what it reminds me of. It's like gambling. It's like how where can I get this so that I And when we have systems like gambling or systems where like you're getting variable reward or dopamine from something or a sense of like you're winning from a purchase, that is in many ways going to hardwire your brain to make decisions that probably aren't in your best interest. Like I love the example you said of like if there has been a period of time that you've really wanted an item, take advantage of sales. But I also think that the flash sales like you were talking about provide us. with a lot of instant gratification that we're very used to getting from everything else in our society. Instant gratification from our phones. Like instant gratification from express shipping. Like all of these things are like, you can get it now.
大量的即时满足感，而这种即时满足感是我们从现代社会的方方面面中早已习惯获得的。来自手机的即时满足感。来自快递运输的即时满足感。所有这些事情都在传达一个信息：你现在就能得到它。
You can have it now. Low stock. Yeah. It's like low stock or like isn't returning. Yeah. Or what happens? And this was Sal's tip actually in that episode that she learnt from Brittany Saunders who has baked the label. Yeah.
你现在就能拥有它。库存紧张。对。就像是“库存紧张”或者“即将售罄”。对。或者会发生什么呢？这其实是萨尔（Sal）在那期节目里的建议，她是向创立了Baked the Label品牌的布兰妮·桑德斯（Brittany Saunders）学的。对。
She's amazing. I love her. I'm a big fan girl obsessed. And she was saying that brands will be like not returning or it will return. Like it'll come back in stock and it'll be like like this sale is the final sale. Like it's never coming back. But because it didn't sell out and they had heaps of stock left over. So they said it sold out. It didn't really sell out.
她太棒了。我超级喜欢她，简直是个狂热粉丝。她说，品牌会故意挂出“不再补货”或者“即将回归”的标语。就像是“这次促销是最后一次”。“以后再也不会补货了”。但实际上是因为东西根本没卖完，他们还剩下堆积如山的库存。所以他们才宣称已经售罄。其实根本没有售罄。
But they're just tricking you to think that there's this demand for this item because we all want to be on trend and not toogy. or cringe or out of date. And it's just really exhausting because if you constantly are chasing a trend or a type of girl that TikTok is, you know, deeming the it girl of the month, you will never actually develop a sense of self. And I have fallen into this as have many other women and men and humans in general of, you know, that fear of rejection and not quite knowing who they are
但他们只是在欺骗你，让你觉得这款商品有着巨大的需求，因为我们所有人都想赶潮流，不想显得很老土（Chuggy）、尴尬或者过时。这真的让人筋疲力尽，如果你一直在追逐 TikTok 封为“本月It girl”的某种潮流或某种特定类型的女孩，你将永远无法真正培养出真正的自我意识。我和其他许多女性、男性以及所有人一样，也曾陷入过这种陷阱，总是害怕被拒绝，却又不太清楚自己究竟是谁，
because they're constantly adjusting themselves to be that. And it's where you develop this idea of like your style uniform. And I think it's really good to be able to identify the things that it's kind of the same as a capsule wardrobe. But when we say capsule wardrobe, we think like blue jeans, white teas and a black blazer, which again, love that. I was going to say that's literally your go-to outfit. I know. That is my go-to. It's a grey men's laser from Deep Up and I love her.
因为他们一直在不断调整自己去迎合那些标准。这就是为什么你会形成“穿搭制服”（style uniform）的概念。我觉得能够识别出那些单品其实挺好的，这有点类似于胶囊衣橱。但每当我们提到胶囊衣橱时，我们就会想到：蓝色牛仔裤、白色T恤和黑色西装外套——再次申明，我超爱这个。我正想说，这简直就是你的标配服装。我知道。那确实是我的标配。是一件来自Depop的灰色男士西装外套，我可太爱它了。
I once spilled oil on her. It was a bad day that day, but I got it out. Wow. Thank you. That's amazing. But my capsule wardrobe also includes vintage banties and cowboy boots. Yeah. Like if I'm going out on the weekend and I'm just going to chuck on a banty, some cowboy boots,
我有一次不小心在上面滴了油。那天的确是个糟糕的日子，不过我后来把它洗掉了。哇。谢谢。太厉害了。但我的胶囊衣橱里也包含复古乐队T恤和西部牛仔靴。对。如果我周末要出门，我就会随手套上一件乐队T恤、一双西部牛仔靴，
and I'm going to be so comfortable and I feel really hot in it. I feel like a badass. Also like sparkles. Like it doesn't have to be plain to be part of like how you see your style. And I think it's something that happens the further we get into our 20s where we're like, I actually don't want to dress for others anymore. And I don't want it to be. And I know that we're talking a lot.
我会觉得无比舒适，而且穿上它让我觉得自己火辣极了。我感觉自己像个女硬汉。还有亮片。亮片也是如此。它不需要平平无奇，也能成为你个人穿搭风格的一部分。而且我认为随着我们年龄渐长、进入二十岁的中后期，这种转变就会发生，我们会开始觉得：“我其实不想再为别人穿衣打扮了。”而且我不希望它……我知道我们聊了很多
lot about clothes, but it really is with anything, you know, like, skincare with, like, products in your home, with, like, interior design, with new cars, like, everything that you are being convinced to buy is not going to feel a void of who you are. Being like, I hate myself, I'll buy a concealer. Yeah. Like, that's not going to help, babe. It might make you feel a little better. Well, this is the big thing that I also want to talk about, which is retail therapy.
关于衣服的话题，但其实不仅是衣服，任何事情都是如此，你知道的，比如护肤品、家里的家居用品、室内设计、新车……所有那些被说服去购买的东西，都无法填补你内心的空虚。比如心里想着：“我讨厌我自己，我去买个遮瑕膏吧。”对。这种想法是帮不了你的，亲爱的。它可能会让你感觉稍微好一点。好吧，这也是我同样想讨论的重大话题，那就是零售疗法。
Obviously, that is deeply psychological. cool. We use a lot of different tactics to kind of create euphoria, like artificial euphoria and joy for ourselves. And anything that creates dopamine, as we've explained, shopping does, can be kind of, not manipulated, but like can be disturbed in our brain. We can get addicted to like the wrong types of dopamine. Yeah. It's like, I think that's why TikTok and social media and shopping are so closely linked because they both give you dopamine. So that's why it's so easy. to transition between the two. So it's like, okay, you see the new trending skincare or beauty item, which again, they always tend to be like high end or expensive. There's definitely some like drugstore
显而易见，这有着深刻的心理学根源。我们使用了许多不同的策略来为自己制造欣快感，也就是人工的欣快感和快乐。正如我们所解释的，任何能产生多巴胺的事物——购物正是如此——都可能会被扰乱，或者说可能在我们的大脑中被干扰。我们可能会对错误类型的多巴胺产生上瘾。对。我觉得这也是为什么TikTok、社交媒体和购物会如此紧密相连，因为它们都能给你提供多巴胺。所以这就是为什么在它们之间切换会如此轻松。比如，好吧，你看到了最新潮流的护肤品或美容产品，而它们往往也总是高端货或奢侈品。当然现在也确实有一些开架替代品
or juke's like coming out right. But it's like, like, Dyson. Like Dyson is $900 and it's like the hair product. It's like the it's the hair product you buy. It had great sales on Black Friday that I was like, go. If you want it, you buy it. We're not seeing a sale like this again for a while. But, it's like that's become the product to buy for hair right but that's really expensive like if you went like pre-tick-tock times i don't think there would be many people that were spending nine hundred dollars on a hair styler and it's because like we see all this stuff and we're getting the dopamine from tic-tok as we're scrolling and then we we open up the shopping and we're still in that dopamine high and then it's kind of like we're chasing it being like oh the
或者平替正在涌现。但比如像戴森。戴森的美发产品售价高达900美元。这就是那种你会去买的美发产品。它在黑色星期五期间有很多超棒的折扣，当时我都想说：买吧。如果你想要，就买它。我们有一段时间不会再看到这样的折扣了。但是，这就成了人们买来做头发的标配产品，对吧？然而这真的太贵了。如果在TikTok出现之前的时代，我想不会有那么多人愿意花900美元去买一个美发造型器。这正是因为我们看到了所有这些东西，当我们一边刷着TikTok一边沉浸在多巴胺的高潮中时，然后我们打开购物软件，依然处于那种多巴胺飙升的状态中，这就有点像是我们在追逐那种感觉，心想：“噢，
if I don't buy it, that dopamine goes down. And this isn't a conscious thing, but this is like the cycle that's happening of why we see something. We open the link or we open like whatever internet app there is and we buy it straight away. Oh my God, because I've done that and you know I've done this. Well, we were speaking about this recently. I had like a really terrible week.
如果我不买它，多巴胺就会下降。这并不是一个有意识的过程，但这就像是一个循环，让我们一看到某样东西，就会立刻打开链接或某个购物软件并直接买下来。天哪，因为我也这样做过，而且你知道我也干过这种事。嗯，我们最近刚聊过这个。我之前过了一个非常糟糕的一周。
And I really wanted a pair of Adidas stambas. And I said in the back of my mind and I said this to you, I was like, I know that these. are going to go out of style in about six months. Like, I know it. I know it. And I was telling myself again and again, like, don't buy these. Don't buy these.
如果我不买它，多巴胺就会下降。”这不是一种有意识的行为，但这正是为什么我们一看到某种东西就会立刻打开链接或任何网购应用并直接下单的幕后循环机制。天哪，因为我做过这种事，你也知道我做过。对了，我们最近才聊过这个。我当时经历了一个非常糟糕的一周。
They're just another trending shoe. Yeah, they look great right now. But the reason you think they look great is because it allows you to fit into like the trend, the uniform, the vision of the day. And then I had a really terrible day. Obviously, my like, my mood was low. My dopamine levels were low. And I was like, you know what?
它们只是又一双流行鞋款而已。对，它们现在看起来确实很好看。但你觉得它们好看的原因，是因为这能让你融入当下的潮流、统一的穿搭风格和审美愿景中。然后我那天过得很糟糕。显然，我的情绪很低落，多巴胺水平也很低。我就想，你知道吗？
You know what's going to make me feel better is a new purchase. as an impulse buy is some retail therapy because it's going to provide me with not just a dopamine hit but a sense of control, a sense of agency that like, yes, all these other things in my life might be really difficult, but I can place this new item in the center and then I feel like there's a new thing in my life to be happy about. It's so deeply like emotional. I get it though because as well there are moments that I'm like, just do it. Like yeah, like if you want to like if you've had a really crap week. Yeah.
你知道什么能让我感觉好点吗？就是买个新东西。作为一种冲动消费，也就是所谓的“零售疗法”，因为它不仅能带给我多巴胺的刺激，还能带来一种掌控感、一种自主感。就好像，是的，我生活中的其他事情可能真的很艰难，但我可以把这个新物品放在中心位置，然后我觉得生活中又多了一件值得高兴的事。这真的很感性。不过我懂，因为有时候我也会觉得，买就对了。就像是，如果你的确度过了糟糕的一周。
But I think knowing that this isn't going to fix it. Like this isn't going to like, you know, if you broke up with your partner and you're heartbroken and you really just want to feel something nice and you want to buy something, I'm kind of like, okay, but within reason. Like we're going to go with like a cute little $30 purchase. We're not going to go with like something really expensive and we're not going to make a habit out of it. I think knowing the things that you can do to kind of get that control back.
但我觉得，只要明白这并不能真正解决问题。就像这不会，你知道的，如果你跟你伴侣分手了，你心碎了，你真的很想感受一点美好的东西，然后你想买个东西，我心里会觉得，好吧，但要适可而止。我们就买个30块钱左右可爱的小东西。我们不会去买很贵的东西，也不会把它变成一种习惯。我觉得清楚自己可以做哪些事情来重新找回这种掌控感……
that isn't shopping is really helpful so that you don't get in that loop. So for example, I absolutely froth like a Pinterest scroll. Like Pinterest is like play shopping to me. Oh, that's such a good way to play. Yeah, like it's like I feel like because I love scrolling through and like looking at things on sale and looking at things I want and thinking about how I would style them because I do genuinely just love fashion and beauty and it is such a passion of mine. But I'm not a Kardashian and I can't just sit there and scroll and buy, unfortunately.
而且不是通过购物的方式，这真的很有帮助，这样你就不会陷入那个死循环。比如，我真的超级喜欢刷Pinterest。对我来说，Pinterest就像是虚拟购物。哦，这真的是个很好的方法！对，就好像……我觉得因为我喜欢到处滑动浏览、看打折商品、看我想要的东西，并思考我会如何搭配它们，因为我是真心喜欢时尚和美妆，这真的是我的一个巨大热情所在。但我也不是卡戴珊，不幸的是，我不能就坐在那儿一边狂刷一边下单。
I do think I was meant to be one, but I think something just got messed up. Yeah. Yeah. I think like someone filed something wrong upstairs and then. Yeah, I do see that happening. Yeah. It's fine. We'll figure it out in the next lifetime.
我确实觉得我本来应该是她们的一员，但中间好像出了点差错。对。对。我觉得就像是楼上有人把文件搞错了，然后……对，我确实觉得有这种可能。没关系。我们下辈子再弄清楚吧。
You'll come back as like Stormy's baby in like 50 years. Oh my God. It's not weird to say. She's still child. I'm like, I'm still alive and I see like a picture of you in like the magazine. I'm like, that baby looks very familiar. Yeah. The baby starts throwing up like the horns and like singing ACD.C.
你会在50年后投胎成为Stormi的小孩。天哪。这样说好像不奇怪吧。她还是个孩子。我当时就想，我还活着，然后我在杂志上看到你的照片。我心想，这个婴儿看起来好面熟啊。对。那个婴儿开始举起摇滚的手势，然后唱着AC/DC的歌。
and you're like, shit. Rubbing my eyes. You know what? She said she was going to do it. She did it. Everyone's going to call me crazy. Yeah, they're like, it's Alex and they're like, all right, time for gym to go have some chats. Time for her.
然后你会想，靠。揉揉眼睛。你知道吗？她说她会做到的，她真的做到了。每个人都会觉得我疯了。对，他们会觉得，那是亚历山大，他们会说，好了，吉姆该去聊聊天了。轮到她了。
Yeah. But like Pinterest shopping is so good because you can kind of make, believe, shop and see what you already have. Like I feel like a lot of the items that are going to be coming up on your Pinterest are probably items that you already have in your wardrobe. So you can see all the things that you already have in your wardrobe. So you can see all that. the different ways that you can style it and get like that cost per wear from your shopping and make cute little Pinterest boards and it really helps me also understand items I want because if I have saved like I had a thing recently that I really wanted a pair of like lace just like plain black lace pants
对。但是Pinterest购物太棒了，因为你可以假装购物，还能看看你已经有什么。我觉得那些经常出现在你Pinterest上的单品，很可能就是你衣柜里本来就有的东西。所以你可以看看你衣柜里已经拥有了的所有东西，然后你可以看到所有这些不同的搭配方式，从而最大化利用你的衣柜，还能制作可爱的小Pinterest看板。这真的也能帮我弄清楚我到底想要什么单品，因为如果我保存了——我最近就有一个想法，我非常想要一条那种蕾丝的、简简单单的黑色蕾丝裤……
to like style with a black blazer over the top. That would have been really cute. Right. And so I was like, oh but I don't know if I'm going to wear them a lot. And for like a month I've just been saving pins of like these just lace pants and I'm like, okay, I want these. Like I know. And I've got so many different ways to style them in my Pinterest board that I know I want them. And I kind of didn't make the knee jerk purse purchase because I was doing it on Pinterest and I was having like a Tee fun little girly time on there. You're getting your dopamine and you're also getting your sense of control.
想在外面套一件黑色西装外套来搭配。那一定超级好看。对吧。然后我就想，哦，但我不知道我会不会经常穿它。有一个月的时间，我一直在收集这些蕾丝裤的图片，我心想，好吧，我真的想要这个。我很确定。而且我的Pinterest看板上有各种各样的搭配方式，我知道我是真的很想要它。我并没有冲动消费，因为我是在Pinterest上完成的，而且我在上面度过了一段非常开心、充满少女心的时光。你既得到了多巴胺，又获得了掌控感。
And you're also getting like you're doing your research. Yeah. Also the other thing I would do is like go clean something. Like if you're feeling really shit and you're there and you just won't buy something, I would like just go wipe down your bench top. Yeah. or like just vacuum something. My roommate was so, my old roommate was so good at this,
而且你还在做研究。对。另外我还会做的一件事就是去打扫卫生。如果你感觉真的很糟糕，待在那儿，但你又下定决心不买东西，我就会去把操作台擦干净。对，或者去吸吸尘什么的。我的室友以前特别擅长这个……
good slash bad that like at 9.30, she would just start vacuuming. And I would be like, like I was awake, so it's fine. But I'd be like, are we good? And she was like, I need to control something. And I was like, okay, that's fine. That's good edge. But then you also get the satisfaction and like all the good brain juices from having like a clean space.
这种习惯说好也不好，就是在晚上九点半，她会突然开始吸尘。我会觉得，我当时醒着，所以没关系。但我会问，我们没事吧？她会说，我需要掌控点什么。然后我就想，好吧，没问题。这倒是个好办法。但接着你也能从拥有一个干净整洁的空间中获得满足感和满满的快乐脑内物质。
And I reckon half the purchases you think about making, if you go and do something else, whether it's, you know, read a book for 30 minutes, clean your space. Clean your water about. Yeah. That's a really good one. Because honestly, who likes doing washing and you're just going to keep buying more and more? I'm speaking from experience.
而且我估计，你脑子里想买的东西里有一半，如果你去干点别的，不管是看30分钟的书，还是打扫一下空间。清理一下你的水杯。对。这真的是个好主意。因为说实话，谁喜欢洗衣服呢？你只会一直买个不停。我是说真的，我有经验。
Particularly underwear. And you've got nowhere to put it. And it just keeps coming out. And then you just have a messy room all the time and it's the worst. Yeah. So yeah. I love that. We're going to take a little bit of a break.
尤其是内衣。而且你无处安放。它们还源源不断地买进来。结果你的房间里就一直乱糟糟的，这感觉太糟糕了。对啊。所以，是的。我很喜欢这样。我们要稍作休息。
But when we come back, I really want to talk about how you can tell whether it's an impulse purchase or a need. and the experience of buyer's remorse. So we'll be back with you shortly. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%,
但等我们回来后，我真的很想聊聊你该如何分辨这是冲动消费还是刚需，以及买完东西后后悔的体验。我们一会儿就回来。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可供选择时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇特的现代世界中培养应变能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，带大家看透充斥在健康产业中不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会导致发炎。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我们弄错了。我们在世界上所恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你就会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。名字是 T-W-O-Persent，可在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆（Little Kim）的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jette. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在播客《Look Back at It》中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jette）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，他滔滔不绝地谈论了 80 年代的快克（毒品）。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅是因为快克。只要你们想听，我随时都可以聊快克。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的线索了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病也摆到台面上来了。谢谢你把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
是的。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师——
Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. and we don't know when we've done enough.
基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。但我们却依然在追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世界上当一个好人很重要，还是你当好人只是因为你害怕？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free. iHeartRadio app search
这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地去成为一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序，搜索
Learn the Hard Way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中的明显矛盾。这引发了一场长达数年的法律之战来证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
你对某个人伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。
Greg Lesbian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud, charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
格雷格·莱斯利（Greg Lesbian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，来自马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. All righty. So obviously, when we're really aware of our tendency to impulse by, sometimes we can actually go in the opposite direction. Where we never spend money, we become very frugal. That can come at the expense of like spending money on things that are necessary, spending money on, you know, experiences with friends. But I really do want to focus on items that you actually need. So how can you kind of tell the difference between an impulse purchase and a need? So similar to what I was saying before, an impulse purchase is something that hasn't even dawned on you that you want it. Like you've seen this one thing and you're like, I need that. And again, there are times that maybe you do need that thing.
在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听播客《Love Trapped》。好啦。很显然，当我们清楚地意识到自己有冲动消费的倾向时，有时我们实际上会走向相反的方向。也就是我们绝不花钱，变得非常节俭。这可能会以牺牲那些必要开销为代价，比如把钱花在必需品上，花在与朋友的聚会上，你知道的。但我真的很想把重点放在你真正需要的物品上。那么，你该如何分辨冲动消费和刚需呢？所以，类似于我之前所说的，冲动消费是指那种你甚至从未想过自己想要的东西。就像你看到了某个东西，然后你就想：我需要这个。而且话说回来，有时你可能确实需要那个东西。
But I don't think anyone should make a knee jerk reaction within 24 hours on something. So the best thing you can do in life, shopping, relationships with yourself is sleep on it. Like just go to bed and if you wake up and the first thing you think about is that, then I'm like, okay, maybe we'll start thinking about it. And then if you don't even think about it and you potentially even forget about it for like two weeks, and you're like, oh, I kind of, oh, I saw it. And it maybe comes up as an ad because your cookies have been dropped so your internet knows that you want this item now. So it's going to start serving your ads for it.
但我认为任何人都不应该在 24 小时内对某样东西做出本能的冲动反应。所以你在生活中、购物时、处理与自己的关系时，能做的最好的事情就是：让它过夜再决定。就像是去睡一觉，如果你醒来时脑子里想的第一件事依然是它，那我觉得，好吧，也许我们可以开始考虑它了。然后，如果你甚至都没有想起它，甚至可能把它忘得精光，比如持续两周，然后你突然觉得：哦，我好像……哦，我看到了。它可能会作为广告再次出现，因为你的 Cookie 信息已经被植入了，所以你的互联网现在知道你想要这个商品。于是它就会开始向你推送相关的广告。
If that's the only time that you're thinking of it is because you're seeing it online or in ads, it's probably an impulse purchase. Like you probably don't actually want this because there hasn't been a moment in your life that you've navigated through your life. And this thing would have been a relief to like a problem or a want or whatever. Because for example, if you're going to go out for drinks and you've realized, oh crap, I actually don't have mascara. Yeah. That's when you're like, okay, I need mascara.
如果这是你唯一想起它的时刻，仅仅是因为你在网上或广告中看到了它，那它很可能就是一次冲动消费。就像你其实并不真的想要它一样，因为在你的生活中，从未有过这样的时刻：你在生活中遇到困扰，而这个东西能够解决你的某个问题、满足你的某种需求，或是别的什么。因为举个例子，如果你准备出门喝一杯，结果你发现：糟糕，我其实没有睫毛膏。对。那就是你会觉得：好吧，我需要睫毛膏。
Yeah. That's when you can. I don't actually have a pair of socks. Yeah. And no one ever has enough socks. Yeah. Honestly, I'm one of those people.
没错。那就是你觉得……我其实没有一双袜子。对。而且永远没有人会觉得自己的袜子够穿。真的。说实话，我就是那种人。
Can never be an impulse by. No. But absolutely, no, absolutely not. I was passionate about the sockies. But those are kind of the moments that I would think if there's something popping up in your everyday life and you're like, oh shit, I need that. Then you know you can go buy that. And then the other thing that I think I do is I kind of make sure I earn.
这绝对不可能是冲动消费。不。但是绝对不行，绝对不行。我对袜子可是充满热情的。但这些就是那种特定的时刻，当你的日常生活中突然冒出某种东西，而你惊呼：哦操，我需要那个！那你就会知道，你可以去买它了。然后我觉得我会做的另一件事是，我会确保自己“赢下”
the shop so it's like I will go and I will find it on sale and I will start price matching. So I will go to like all the retailers that stock it and I will go on their little chat pot thing and I'll be like do you price match this? And this has been something that I've been relentless with. Wait, that's so smart. Yeah. So like J.B. Highfi, the iconic David Jones, Maya, like the good guys, Harvey Norman, they all price match.
这件商品。意思就是，我会去网上找折扣，然后开始比价。所以我会去所有出售它的零售商那里，找到他们的小聊天机器人，然后我会问：你们有这个商品的保价吗？我一直对这件事锲而不舍。等等，这也太聪明了吧。对。所以就像 JB Hi-Fi、Iconic、大卫琼斯（David Jones）、Myer、The Good Guys、哈维诺曼（Harvey Norman），它们全部都有价格匹配。
Yeah. Jet Star price match, chemist warehouse price match. There's so many places like price match. People who don't live in Australia, these are like huge Australian brands. So I'm assuming that like in other countries you might find a very similar system in place. Yep. And so then I go through price matching and then I start looking at like cash back. So I look on shop back and I see if I can get shot back for certain brands and that's kind of where I'll go to price matches.
对。捷星航空（Jet Star）有价格匹配，药妆店 Chemist Warehouse 也有价格匹配。有太多地方都可以进行价格匹配了。对于不住在澳大利亚的人来说，这些都是澳大利亚非常大的品牌。所以我猜在其他国家，你可能会发现一个非常类似的系统正在运行。没错。然后我会浏览价格匹配，接着我开始查看返现。所以我会在 ShopBack 上查看，看看我能不能为某些品牌获得 ShopBack 返现，这就是我进行价格匹配的地方。
because if there's like 20% cash back at David Jones, then I'm going to go price match at David Jones and get a further 20% cash back. And it's like doing all this work that will show me if I really want the product. Because if you can't be bothered and there are moments that I can't be asked to go and do this and like really focus on getting a really good deal, then I don't want it.
因为如果在大卫琼斯有 20% 的返现，那我就去大卫琼斯做价格匹配，并额外获得 20% 的返现。这就好像做所有这些工作，来向我证明我是不是真的想要这个产品。因为如果你嫌麻烦——有时候我也会懒得去搞这些，无法真正专注于拿到一个极好的优惠——那我就不想要它了。
Yeah. Then it's not the thing. Like I was really tossing up with getting my boyfriend, Rob, don't listen. I'm pretty sure he's not listening. Just in case. No, he's always like when. Whenever I do something, he's always like, can I listen? No.
对。那它就不是那个东西。就像我当时真的很纠结要不要给我男朋友罗布买……罗布，别听。我确信他没在听。以防万一嘛。不，他总是这样，每当我做点什么的时候，他总是会问：我能听听吗？不。
I'm like, no, go away. This isn't for you. For the girls only. For the girls, for girls. I was really tossing up between like an Ura ring, which is like basically an Apple Watch in a ring and a Weber barbecue. And so this is probably a good tip for people that are doing Christmas shopping. And what I do to ask people what they want for Christmas and I make sure I get them a good
我说：不，走开。这不是给你的。只限女生。为了女生，为了女孩们。我当时真的很纠结，是在 Oura 戒指（基本上就是把 Apple Watch 做成戒指）和一个韦伯（Weber）烧烤架之间二选一。所以这可能对正在准备圣诞购物的人是个好建议。我平时用来问别人圣诞想要什么礼物的方法，能确保我送出好礼，
present because I am an elite. You're an excellent shopper. I am an elite gift giver. Oh, I bet as well. Yes, as well, but shopper and gift giver, is I don't ask people, what do you want for Christmas? Because, like, nine times out of ten, someone's going to say, oh, I don't know. I don't know. Or they'll feel bad to tell you what they want.
因为我是精英。你是个出色的购物狂。我是个精英送礼达人。哦，我敢打赌你也是个购物能手。是的，我也是，既是购物达人也是送礼达人。我不问别人：“你圣诞想要什么？”因为，十有八九，别人会说：“哦，我不知道。我不知道。”或者他们会不好意思告诉你他们到底想要什么。
Yeah. Because we're, like, taught that it's greedy. Yeah. But what I ask is, like, do you have any, like, passions for next year? Or are there any new focuses you want to, like, get into? Oh. Or when are you at your happiest? So those.
是的。因为我们被教导说那样显得很贪婪。是的。但我的问法是，比如：“你对明年有什么热爱的事吗？”或者“有没有什么你想投入精力的新关注点？”哦。或者“你什么时候最快乐？”所以这些……
A beautiful series of questions. Yeah, so those can kind of tell you what people want. So, like, I asked my boyfriend and I said, do you have any passions that you want to lean into next year? And so I was tossing up between a fitness tracker and a Weber bump here. He goes, he goes, he goes, running and cooking. And I was like, fuck. I was like, that's both of them.
这是一系列很棒的问题。是的，所以这些可以大致告诉你人们想要什么。比如，我问我男朋友，我说：“明年你有什么想要深入培养的热爱吗？”当时我在健身追踪器和韦伯烧烤架之间纠结。他回答说，他回答说，他说：跑步和烹饪。当时我就想：靠。我心想：这俩他全都占了。
Oh, no. Yes. I was like, ah, damn it. What's one that you can do, maybe like a nutrition pouch or something? Yeah, but I was just like, yeah, but honestly, I was like, the URA ring was like $400 AUD and I started going into my little price match shop back world for the local barbecue and I was like, do you know what? And I ended up getting it like 50% off.
哦，不。是的。我当时想：啊，可恶！有没有哪个是你能够……比如说送个营养包或者别的什么的？对，但我当时就觉得，说实话，Oura 戒指大概要 400 澳元，然后我开始进入我的比价和 ShopBack 世界去挑选那个本地烧烤架，心想：你知道吗？我最后以 5 折的价格把它买下来了。
That's actually incredible. It was wild. It's worth it. He's going to love that. And then like since then I've like heard him say all these little things about cooking that I'm like, I'm so excited to give that to him. Yeah. And it wasn't just like this weird like knee jerk reaction of buying him something that was
这真的太不可思议了。简直太疯狂了。太值了。他一定会超级喜欢这个。然后从那以后，我听到他说所有这些关于烹饪的小事，我就觉得：我太期待把这个送给他了！对。这不仅仅是一种奇怪的、冲动性的反应——去给他买一件非常昂贵的东西，
really expensive because that's what the Uruhrer ring was. would have been. It was like, I saw it and I was like, oh, that's cool. And it was $100 off and as well, especially for sales, whether it's Black Friday or whatever time of the year it is, it's like, our biggest sale of the year. Lies. Yeah, lies and Manelli lies. Lies and Manelli lies. The thing is to realize is like there is absolutely no legislation, rules, anything, around advertising sales. It's also unregulated. Like, I'm going to name drop, but pretty little thing, they always, always have a sale on their site, right? And they have a countdown.
就像 Oura 戒指那样本来会做的那样。而是我看到了它，然后觉得：哦，那个很酷。而且它还便宜了 100 澳元。另外，特别是在大促期间，无论是黑色星期五还是年度的其他什么时间，总会听到类似“我们一年中最大的一次促销”这种话。谎言。是的，全是满嘴跑火车的谎言。满嘴跑火车的谎言。我们需要意识到的事情是，关于广告促销，绝对没有任何法律法规、规章制度或任何限制。这也是不受监管的。比如，我要点名了，PrettyLittleThing（快时尚品牌），他们的网站上总是、永远都在促销，对吧？而且他们还有一个倒计时。
And I swear, I don't know if they still do this because I haven't been on this site for ages. But like, I would say like maybe when I was 20, which was seven years ago. Yeah. It's fine. But they would have like 50% off. And the countdown would never be for more than a day. And then the next day it would just reset. So they just had this countdown that was always like 24 hours.
我发誓，我不知道他们现在是不是还这样，因为我已经很久没上过这个网站了。但大概是在我 20 岁的时候吧，也就是七年前。对，没关系。但他们总是会有 5 折优惠。而且倒计时永远不会超过一天。然后第二天它就会重置。所以他们只是搞了一个永远都是 24 小时的倒计时。
They know their psychology. Yeah. I mean, it might have been give or take a little bit less, a little bit more. I don't know, pretty little thing you can't sue me. Disclaimer. Yeah. But it was always like that. Yeah.
他们太懂心理学了。对。我的意思是，可能会多一点或少一点，差不太多吧。我不知道，PrettyLittleThing，你可别告我诽谤。免责声明。对。但它一直都是这样的。对。
Well, that's what we were talking about before. Yeah. I think when we were going back to, I love that you did your like research before making a purchase. That is a big way of telling whether something is an impulse buy versus a need is because you won't look for other options. So it's like, for example, if you need a new pair of runners because your O1 have holes in them.
嗯，这就是我们之前谈到的。对。我想当我们回到……我很喜欢你在购买前做研究的那种做法。这是判断某样东西到底是冲动消费还是刚需的一个重要方法，因为如果是刚需，你就不会只看单一选项。所以，举个例子，如果你需要一双新的跑步机鞋，因为你旧的那双磨出了洞。
Yes. You are going to look for the best value for money. You are going to look for the best pair that's going to last you a while. Yeah. If it was an impulse buy, you'd be like, oh, those are fine because our standards for an impulse buyer lower because we're actually not actually looking for the purchase. We're looking for the dopamine. We're looking for the control.
是的。你会去寻找性价比最高的。你会去寻找最耐穿的那一双。对。如果这是一次冲动消费，你就会觉得：哦，那双也行。因为我们对冲动消费的标准更低，因为我们其实并不是在寻找商品本身。我们在寻找多巴胺。我们在寻找掌控感。
We're looking for other things here. I also think as well, like, buyers remorse is going to happen. So like don't beat yourself up for those moments that maybe you have bought something and you're like, oops, this was a bit of a mistake. Like, because as well, we're not. we're not as a collective, as a community, we're not shopping at places that we can't return items. If something's final sale and you haven't been able to like try it on or like actually touch it, feel it and see it in real life, I would really recommend not buying it.
我们在寻找其他东西。我也觉得，买完之后感到后悔是难免的。所以，当你偶尔买下某样东西，然后觉得“哎呀，这好像有点买错了”时，不要太苛责自己。因为毕竟，我们作为一个整体、作为一个社群，我们并不会去那些无法退货的地方购物。如果某件商品是最终清仓（Final Sale）、且你无法试穿、甚至无法亲手触摸和亲眼看到它，我真的强烈建议你不要买。
But as well, a lot of the time you can return it, we're just really lazy. That's true. Yeah. That like the idea of going to the post office, which is difficult because a lot of us work nine to five and the post office is open from like nine to four. at some places. Yeah, in some places. Yeah, it's like, how did they come up with that system? Yeah, and like, not of us really.
但话说回来，很多时候其实都是可以退货的，只是我们真的很懒。确实如此。对。比如要去邮局寄快递这件事本身就很麻烦，因为我们很多人都是上九晚五的班，而邮局的营业时间大概是从九点到四点。在某些地方。是的，在某些地方。对，人们就会想：他们到底是怎么想出这种制度的？是的，而且我们当中真的没有几个人……
Like, who owns a printer? I do because I needed to get... Oh, I don't. Oh, I bought one because I just would not go to the post office. And I was like, I'm losing so much money in these clothes that I was like, I'm just going to start printing my own returns labels. Yeah. And then being able to just ship it back.
比如说，谁家里会有打印机？我有，因为我需要……噢，其实我没有。噢，我买了一个，因为我就是不想去邮局。当时我想，退这些衣服让我亏了好多钱，所以我干脆自己打印退货标签算了。对。然后就能直接把东西寄回去。
But, like, making sure that you do that because I read this stat the other day and it was like 30% of online purchases, like, get returned. that's just the items that get returned. Like, I feel like that number would be so... I would say it's like at least 50% for like items that didn't get returned, but then also didn't get used. Yeah, I would say it's like 50% of items online. I'm making this stat up, by the way.
但是，比如，一定要这么做，因为我前几天看了一个统计数据，上面说30%的网购商品都会被退货。这还只是被退货的商品。我觉得这个数字甚至会更……我觉得对于那些没退货、但也根本没用过的人来说，这个比例至少有50%。对，我觉得大概50%的网购商品都是这样。顺便说一句，这个数据是我瞎编的。
This is just a guess. I think that's true. But that people wish they didn't buy. Yeah. I'm sure there's something on there sitting in the internet. Well, we have to find it out. Yeah. Because it's like, so buyers remorse, there's two versions of it.
这纯属瞎猜。我觉得这是真的。但人们确实会后悔自己买过。对。我敢肯定网上某处有这种数据。好吧，我们得把它找出来。对。因为这就是买家后悔，它有两种类型。
I look into this. There's buyers remorse. force in which you've spent a lot of money and you're feeling a sense of loss from your attachment for the money. So like for example, if you're saving for a home or a car, you have spent so much time earning that money that when you finally spend it, you feel this like, and you've been so strong not spending it, that then suddenly you spend it all because you've permitted yourself to spend it all. But like your brain, your cognition is kind of like taking a little while to shift into that new gear of like there is permissiveness there to spend it. Same with people who say for like being
我研究过这个。有一种买家后悔，是那种你花了很多钱，然后因为你对这笔钱有感情，所以会产生一种失落感。比如说，如果你在存钱买房或买车，你花了很多时间去赚这笔钱，以至于当你终于花掉它时，你会产生这种感觉——而且你一直很克制不乱花钱，结果突然之间你把它全花光了，因为你允许自己把它们全花光。但是你的大脑、你的认知还需要一点时间来适应那种新状态，去接受“现在可以花钱了”的许可。那些存钱去海外度假的人也是这样，等他们真的去了，就会觉得：“我突然觉得花钱买这个东西好内疚，但事实上，这本来就是我们一直在存钱的目标。”所以，这是第一种买家后悔。
overseas holidays and then they go and they're like, I suddenly feel really guilty for spending money on this thing when in fact actually this is what we've been saving for. So that's one type of like buyers remorse. And the second type comes from this thing called post decision dissonance. And it's particularly to do with impulse purchases. We've said this so many times. It is a, it comes from an emotional urge to purchase something to feel a certain way. It's a way of, you know, self-regulating, of self-soothing. What happens is you buy that item. And then the emotional impulse fades and you're able to see things a little bit more clearly. And it's in that point of like where you feel more rational that you actually understand like the pros and cons of the purchase rather than just the emotional impulse of the purchase.
第二种类型来自一种叫做“决策后失调”的心理现象。它尤其和冲动消费有关。我们已经说过好多次了。这是一种源于情感上的冲动，为了让自己感觉好一点而去购买某样东西。这是一种，你知道的，自我调节、自我安慰的方式。结果就是，你把那个东西买了下来。然后情感冲动消退了，你看待事情也变得稍微清晰了一些。正是在这种你感觉更理智的时刻，你才能真正看清这笔消费的利弊，而不是仅仅被买东西时的情感冲动所左右。
I was going to ask you, what's been your biggest buyer's remorse? Oh my God. I feel like I'm so many. Because I was like I'm fascinated by this. I did a really stupid one recently. And I saw a TikTok. And it was of this like Papperson chair. And so a Papperson chair is like,
我正想问你呢，你最后悔的一笔消费是什么？噢天哪。我觉得我有好多。因为我当时想，我对这个太着迷了。我最近就干了一件非常蠢的事。我刷到一个TikTok视频。视频里是一款Papasan藤椅。Papasan藤椅就是那种，
you've probably seen them, but they look like they're a cane chair that kind of looks like a bit of a cocoon. Oh, those are cool, right? Do they hang? Yeah, they hang or you can put it on a stand and it can either sit up as like a couch or you like then swivel it and it sits as like this little bed. And I saw someone on like book talk reading in theirs and I was like, well, I obviously need that.
你可能见过，它们看起来像是一种藤椅，有点像蚕茧的形状。噢，那些很酷，对吧？它们是悬挂式的吗？对，它们可以悬挂，或者你可以把它放在支架上，它可以立起来当沙发，或者你把它转一下，它就能当一张小床。我看到“读书社群”里有人在里面看书，当时我就想，我显然需要一个这个。
Yeah. And I was like, but like furniture is always expensive. So I was like, I wonder how much it is. And then because I was in this loop and I saw it on Amazon and it was like $170. And I was like, oh my God. And you already had thought it was going to be more expensive. Yeah. So I was like, oh my God, stunning amazing brave.
对。然后我想，但家具总是很贵的。所以我心想，不知道要多少钱。后来因为我一直在刷这东西，在亚马逊上看到了，标价是170美元。然后我想，噢天哪。而且你之前就已经觉得它会更贵了。对。所以我当时想，噢天哪，太惊艳、太棒、太勇敢了。
Come at me. And then bought it. It came and I, you know, made the impulse decision. And it came and I hadn't thought about one of these chairs either. So again, this happens to me too still. and it came and I was like, this package is really small. Maybe I have to build it. I'd just bought the cushion.
冲我来吧。然后就买了。东西送到了，我呢，你知道的，做出了一时冲动的决定。东西到了，其实我之前根本没考虑过要买这种椅子。所以你看，这种事到现在还是会发生在我身上。东西到了之后我说：“这个包裹怎么这么小？也许我得自己组装。”我当时其实只买了个坐垫。
Oh my God. There was no chair. Oh my God. And then I looked up how much the chair was. How much was the chair? $1,500. Oh my God. Yeah.
噢天哪。根本没有椅子。噢天哪。然后我去查了一下那张椅子多少钱。那椅子多少钱？1500美元。噢天哪。对。
So did you buy it? No. I said absolutely not. But I went to Facebook Marketplace and I said, give me one. Did you find one? I did find one on Facebook Marketplace. Yeah. But I then ended up spending, I think it was like another $150 to get the chair, which then, look, I love the chair, but I probably wouldn't have spent $300 on it.
那你买了吗？没有。我说绝对不买。但我上了Facebook Marketplace（脸书二手市场），我说，给我来一个。你找到了吗？我在Facebook Marketplace上找到了一个。对。但最后我还是花了钱，好像又花了150美元才买到那把椅子，结果呢，听着，我很喜欢这把椅子，但我大概不会愿意为它花300美元。
In the first place. Yeah, in the first place, which then collectively ended up being $300. And then there's been other things where I just, like, didn't read the measurements. And I bought the world's tiniest couch. Like, it was. The furniture is one of those ones where I'm like, you should go in and look at that in place. Oh, my God. Yeah.
从一开始。对，从一开始就不会，结果加起来总共花了300美元。还有其他一些东西，我就是没有看尺寸。结果我买了个全世界最小的沙发。就像那样。家具就是那种让我觉得“你应该亲自去现场看看尺寸”的东西。噢，天哪。对。
Oh, my God. Yeah. It's a huge thing. But yeah, there's been like definitely a couple things as well. I think some of my buyer's remorse has come from trying to kind of force an item I really liked in a size that wasn't mine. So either sizing up or sizing down and I would be like, I'll just, I'll make it work. Like maybe it's a big make and I'll just. Or maybe I'm bloated today.
噢，天哪。对。这真的是个大问题。不过，对，确实还有好几件类似的事情。我觉得我的一些买家后悔来自于，试图强行塞下一件我很喜欢、但尺寸根本不适合我的单品。要么买大一码，要么买小一码，然后我就会想：“行吧，我会把它改合适的。也许这个版型偏大，我穿就行了。”或者“也许我今天只是有点腹胀。”
Yeah. That's a big one. And I just will be like, no, it's fine. I'll make it work. And then I get it. And I'm like, one, buying clothes. that aren't going to fit me that I know aren't going to fit me. I'm just going to put them on and feel bad about myself.
对。这很常见。然后我就会想：“不，没关系。我会让它合身的。”结果收到货之后，我就觉得：第一，买那些根本不合身、而且我知道绝对不合身的衣服。我穿上它们只会让自己感觉很糟糕。
So why am I doing this to myself? And two, am I actually going to be bothered to return it? Because we're all lazy in terms of returns. And it's busy. And it's busy time. And like, then you just have to pay for shipping as well. Yeah. Which is just a bummer.
所以我为什么要这么折腾自己？第二，我真的会费心去退货吗？因为在退货这件事上我们都很懒。而且平时很忙。那是一段很忙的时间。而且，退货还得自己付运费。对。这就太扫兴了。
Yeah. So I think those have been some of my buyer's remorse times. But yeah, the chair one on Amazon was a recent one. And I was like, damn it. I get that. And it was an impulse buy. Yeah. I did this with a pair of boots maybe two years ago.
对。所以我觉得这些就是我经历过的一些买家后悔的时刻。不过，对，亚马逊上买椅子的事是不久前发生的，当时我就想：“该死。”我懂那种感觉。而且那是一次冲动消费。对。我大约两年前也对一双靴子干过这种事。
It was like I bought them when I just started making like real adult money. Again, the adult money. Yeah. And I was like, I want those boots. And it was an impulse purchase and I bought them. They were from Alohas. And they actually ended up breaking. Oh no.
就好像我刚开始赚到真正的大人钱时买的。又是大人钱。对。然后我就想：“我想要那双靴子。”那是一次冲动消费，我把它们买了下来。它们是Alohas的鞋。结果它们居然坏了。噢不。
The first time I wore them. They didn't. And then I emailed them and actually I bought them from a different seller. So I hadn't bought them straight from Alohas. And so they couldn't refund me. and it was like such a bummer and I ended up paying so here's the other thing I bought them for $300 I've never spent that much money on an item of clothing shoes ever I'm like very frugal like when I just I just don't do it so I bought them and then I broke them and so I ended up spending another
我第一次穿就坏了。真的假的。然后我给他们发了邮件，但其实我是从另一个卖家那里买的。所以我不是直接从Alohas买的。因此他们无法给我退款。这就太扫兴了，我最后还花了——所以这就是另一回事了，我花了300美元买的，我从来没有在任何一件衣服或鞋子上花过那么多钱，从来没有。我是个非常节俭的人，平时我根本不会这么做。所以我买了它，结果它坏了，于是我最后又花了
$50 fixing them it's the sunk cost fallacy where you're like I've already spent and it's what happened to you as well yeah I already spent this much money to like let that go would be a loss of this money so I just need to go in further because at least that it's that loss a version. Like I should have just returned the fucking cool shit. I should have just like stuck to my guns and been like give me a refund these. Yeah. And I'm I'm not saying anything about. That's when you call me. I need you to make an angry call. I have like been there being like I know my A triple C consumer rights. I'm not getting off. This chat, this contact us chat until you give me a refund. But yeah. I will burn this place.
50美元去修理它们，这就是沉没成本谬误，你会想：“我已经花了不少钱了……”这也是发生在你身上的情况，对吧？“我已经花了这么多钱，如果现在放弃，这些钱就全打水漂了，所以我只能硬着头皮继续花下去，因为至少……”这就是损失厌恶。就像我当时应该直接把那破鞋退了。我应该坚持自己的立场，直接说：“把钱退给我。”对。而且我不是在开玩笑。那是你该给我打电话的时候。我需要你帮我打个生气的电话。我以前也经历过那种情况，心想：“我知道我的澳大利亚竞争和消费者委员会（ACCC）消费者权益。在你们给我退款之前，我是不会挂断这个客服聊天窗口的。”不过，对。我要把这家店给烧了。
If it makes you feel better, I realized another one when you were just talking was I bought like a designer handbag for like $3,000. And it's the only designer handbag I've ever bought and I would never buy a designer handbag ever again. Because I, this was maybe two years ago. And I fell into that whole like, oh, like when you buy your first designer bag, it's this really special thing. and I started getting served, all the ads and all of this stuff. And I, like, achieved something really big at my old job and I got this bonus. And I was like, oh, do you know what?
如果这能让你感觉好受点的话，当你在说话的时候，我想起了另一件事，我曾经花大约3000美元买了一个奢侈品手袋。那是我有生以来买的唯一一个奢侈品手袋，而且我发誓再也不会买奢侈品手袋了。因为我，这大概是两年前的事了。我陷入了那种狂热中，就是“噢，当你买你的第一个奢侈品包时，这是一件非常特别的事情”。然后我开始不断收到各种广告和所有这些内容。我在老东家取得了一个非常大的成就，然后我拿到了一笔奖金。当时我就想：“噢，你知道吗？”
And I think we still weren't allowed to travel yet, maybe. I can't remember. And I was like, and I really wanted this designer bag. And I had wanted it for a while. But when I got it, it was so much money, more money than I've ever spent on anything, like 10 times the amount of money. I was going to say you're not a big spender. No, no, no, no, no. You're not like that.
而且我觉得当时我们可能还不能去旅游，也许吧。我记不清了。当时我就想：“而且我真的非常想要这个奢侈品包。”我渴望它已经有一段时间了。但当我真的买到它的时候，它太贵了，比我以往在任何东西上花的钱都要多得多，大约是10倍的金额。我正想说你不是个大手大脚的人。不，不，不，不，不。你不是那种人。
Like, I am like, get me a good deal. Yeah. Then you get my money. But like, and I just was like, it's too nice. I can't use it. Oh, no. What happens? What happens if someone spills a drink on it?
比如，我喜欢买到划算的交易。对。那样你才能赚到我的钱。但是，当时我只是觉得：它太精致了。我根本舍不得用。噢不。会发生什么？如果有人把饮料洒在上面怎么办？
What happens if it gets stolen? What? Like, because it was so much money and so special in like, quite a time rocks, I then didn't use it for like two years. And I was like, shit. I was like, this was a waste of money that I'm like trying to afford. to force myself to use it more now because I still sometimes have a thing being like, oh, but if like I don't want anything, well, that I have this like fear that if you're going to buy something and it's really, really special that you're going to be like,
如果它被偷了怎么办？什么？因为这花了太多的钱，而且在那种特定的时期显得格外珍贵，所以我接下来大约两年里都没舍得用它。然后我就想：见鬼。我心想：“这简直是在浪费我辛辛苦苦赚来的钱。”我现在正试图强迫自己多用用它，因为我有时心里还是有一个坎，会觉得：“噢，但是如果——我不希望发生任何意外，我有这样一种恐惧，觉得如果你要买一件非常非常特别的东西，你就会觉得：
I'm only going to use this to special occasions. Don't buy it. Your cost per wear is not going to be like useful. It's not going to be the level that it needs to be. That's a big one. It's like from home alone too. He talks about like how he got a pair of rollerblades one year. But he was so scared that they would get dirty that he never used them.
‘我只在特殊的场合才用它。’”那就别买。你的单次使用成本根本不会划算。它达不到你所需要的频率。这真的是个大问题。就像《小鬼当家2》里的情节一样。他谈到自己有一年得到了一双轮滑鞋。但他太害怕它们变脏了，结果一次都没舍得穿。
That's all I can think about. So I wanted to do a quick segue to the last thing I want to talk about. Kind of a double barrel question here. What are some of the things that we should be spending our money on in our 20s? And how can we be better at managing our money such that we don't impulse by? I think first step in managing is managing your money and then figuring out what you need to spend your money on. So there are so many just like free templates that you can literally put into Google. And I know it sounds like.
我脑子里全是这个画面。所以我想快速过渡到我想聊的最后一件事。这里算是一个双管齐下的问题：我们在20多岁时应该把钱花在哪些事情上？我们又该如何更好地管理金钱，从而避免冲动消费？我觉得管理的第一步是管理好你的资金，然后弄清楚你需要把钱花在什么地方。网上真的有超级多免费的模板，你可以直接下载到谷歌表格里。我知道这听起来……
It sounds boring because whenever I would listen to like money podcasts tell me to do this. I was like, I'm not going to do that. But you do really need to just sit down and look at how much money you have coming in and how much money you have going out. I'm not saying you need to look at the last six months, three months or whatever, but even just the last month so that you can get an idea of how much money you do have and don't have. Because if you're getting to the end of the week and people are asking if you want to go out
这听起来很无聊，因为每当我听到那些理财播客让我这么做时，我都想说：“我才不干呢。”但你真的需要静下心来，看看你有多少钱进账，又有多少钱花出去了。我不是说你需要查看过去六个月、三个月或者别的什么时间，哪怕只是上个月的账目也行，这样你就能对自己的财务状况有个大致的了解——到底有多少钱，又没有多少钱。因为如果你到了周末快结束的时候，别人问你想不想出去
for drinks and you're saying, well, I haven't been paid yet, you really need to look at this because it means that you're spending more than you're earning. So you... And that's how you get into debt, which is really scary. Yeah, and that is how you get into debt. That's when you start, you know, abusing things like after pay or like looking into a credit card. Don't get a credit card. No.
喝一杯，而你说：“嗯，我还没发工资呢。”那你真的得好好看看账目了，因为这意味着你的开支已经超过了收入。所以你……这就是你陷入债务的方式，这真的很可怕。对，这确实是你陷入债务的方式。这就是你开始，你知道的，滥用Afterpay（先买后付）之类的服务，或者考虑办信用卡的时候。千万别办信用卡。不。
I think in Australia, it's easier to say that. Yeah. Because we don't have like a credit rating. Yeah. But if you don't need to get a credit card, do not buy a credit. Do not get a credit card. We do have like credit schools though. I actually saw this thing where it's like, apparently they don't look into it as much.
我觉得在澳大利亚，说这话会更容易一些。对。因为我们没有那种信用评分系统。对。但如果你不需要信用卡，千万别去买信用卡的坑。别办信用卡。我们其实也有信用评分之类的东西。我其实看到过一个说法，说是他们好像没那么看重这个。
Oh, they do. You can offer it up. Like, you can give it as evidence, like, being like, I am suitable for a loan. Yeah. never had a credit card, they don't count it against you. No, no, no. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. They will look at it if you have one, but they won't.
噢，他们会的。你可以把它拿出来。比如，你可以把它当作证据，证明“我是个适合贷款的人”。对。如果你从来没有办过信用卡，他们不会因此扣你的分。不，不，不。对，对，对，对。如果你有信用卡，他们会看的，但如果没有……
Yeah, anyhow, don't buy a credit card. Then they're not going to be like, you don't. Yeah, there's no need to get to get one unless you're like really into like the points or whatever. And even then, I think the points, there's so many terms and conditions to it. So I used to be like a credit card. So like she, if she says I'm never getting a credit card, then I'm never getting a credit card. And that's not money advice or financial advice.
不管怎样，别办信用卡。然后他们就不会觉得你没有。对，根本没必要办一张，除非你真的很迷恋积分之类的东西。即便如此，我觉得那些积分里面也有太多的条款和限制。我以前也是个信用卡……所以，既然她说“我绝不办信用卡”，那我也绝不办信用卡。这可不是什么金钱建议或理财建议，
at all, but if someone who wrote about them for a living has not got one, then I'm not getting one. Yeah. Anyhow, there's our first. Yeah. Take a solid look at your finances. Don't get a credit card. Yeah. So I think take a look and then really break down everything you spend so that that kind of shows
完全不是，但如果一个靠写这个为生的人都没办过，那我也坚决不办。好吧，这是我们的第一条建议。对。好好审视一下你的财务状况。别办信用卡。对。所以我觉得先看一看账目，然后把你的每一笔开销都详细拆解开来，这样就能
you how much wiggle room you have with your money and where you want to pull back. So for example, like I always get my nails done every two weeks. I know that's going to be $45. But we don't necessarily put that into our budgeting. we think rent, we think, you know, groceries, we think electricity bills, right? But we don't put in like the little things that we regularly get, like even if that's your five dollar morning coffee. Yeah.
让你看清你还有多少闲钱，以及你想在哪些地方缩减开支。比如，我每两周一定会去做一次美甲。我知道那会花45美元。但我们并不一定会把这个记入预算中。我们只会想到房租、你知道的、买菜的钱、电费，对吧？但我们不会把那些经常产生的小额开销算进去，哪怕那是你每天早上5美元的咖啡。对。
And so find a template or build one if you like that's so easy that you can just like pop the numbers in there as you're spending or at the end of the week. What like my partner and I have started doing, but you can do this on your own or you could do this with your roommates is that we like, poor, like he'll have a beer and I have like a glass of wine at like four o'clock on a Sunday afternoon and we'll like play like some Fleetwood Mac and we'll like look at it and then we'll just kind of like hang out and do it while we're hanging out. Yeah. It's fun. Yeah. So that's like the first thing I would do. And then in terms of thinking about what you need to spend your money on in your 20s, it's very difficult to answer this because our
所以，去找一个模板，或者如果你喜欢的话自己做一个，简单到你可以随时把花销数字输进去，或者在周末时统结算一下。我和伴侣现在开始做的一件事是——你也可以自己做，或者跟室友一起做——我们会倒上一杯，他喝啤酒，我喝一杯葡萄酒，在周日下午四点左右，放点弗利特伍德·迈克乐队（Fleetwood Mac）的音乐，然后查看账单，一边闲聊一边就把账给理了。挺有意思的。对。所以这是我会做的第一件事。然后，关于思考你在20多岁时需要把钱花在什么地方，这个问题其实很难回答，因为我们的
early 20s and our mid 20s and our late 20s all have very, very different paychecks because our early 20s, a lot of us are still at uni and we're probably working part time. Mid 20s. 20s is kind of when we get entry level. Yeah, a full-time job that we kind of tend to see a bit more money, but that's also when we tend to move out. So that's when we're kind of trying to figure out how to budget because we've moved out. And late 20s is when we're like, okay, money. I have money.
20岁出头、20岁中期和20岁后期，收入水平有着非常非常大的差异。因为在20岁出头时，我们很多人还在上大学，可能还在做兼职。20岁中期大概是我们开始找到第一份入门级工作的时候。对，有一份全职工作，我们往往能看到更多的收入，但这也是我们往往开始搬出去住的时候。所以那正是我们因为搬出去而开始摸索如何做预算的阶段。而到了20岁后期，我们就会想：“好吧，我有钱了。我有钱了。”
I need to figure out how to spend money. So I think first things first is it's when you are in that phase of, okay, we're moving out, we're renting. When you're renting, that's going to be the biggest investment. I think your home, where you live, that's your biggest investment because that's your safe space. That is never a bad investment in my eyes. And like, I know that renting at the moment is an absolute dog's breakfast, especially in like Sydney and in Australia. But learning how to kind of manage your money and your home is going to be really, really helpful in the long run that you're never stressed and resentful to pay rent.
“我得弄清楚怎么花钱。”所以我觉得首要的事情是，当你处于那个阶段——也就是搬出去住、开始租房的时候。当你租房时，那将是你最大的投资。我认为你的家、你的居住地，才是你最大的投资，因为那是你的安全空间。在我眼里，这绝对不是一个糟糕的投资。而且，我知道目前的租房市场简直烂透了，尤其是在悉尼和澳大利亚。但学会如何管理你的金钱和你的家，从长远来看会非常非常有帮助，能让你永远不会为了交房租而感到压力山大和心生怨恨。
Because that is huge. Yeah. Because I know like we're never going to be like, yay, I'm paying off someone's mortgage. but living within your means but somewhere that feels like home is going to really be helpful like I always think investing in your home and good quality and the things that you use every day is never going to be a bad investment for example sheets if you have like the expendable income to spend a little bit more on really good quality sheets that's going to make getting into bed at the end of a really long hard day that little bit nicer or like bed frame mattress yeah
因为这太重要了。对。因为我知道我们永远不会说：“太棒了，我在帮别人还房贷呢。”但量入为出，并且住在那个感觉像家的地方，真的会非常有帮助。我一直觉得，投资你的家、投资好品质的东西、投资你每天都会用到的东西，永远都不会是一笔坏投资。比如床单，如果你有可支配收入，能在质量非常好的床单上多花一点钱，那会在漫长辛苦的一天结束时，让你钻进被窝的那一刻变得更加美好。或者买个好床架、好床垫。对。
bed frame mattress even cookware like I would say that's maybe more of like investment in your late 20s. Yeah. And you can get that for like quite cheap actually. Yeah. I love that when I moved out. Facebook Marketplace is your best friend in your 20s. I'm telling like there are so many things that I would say one thing to invest in in your
床架、床垫甚至锅具之类的，我觉得这更像是二十多岁时的投资。对啊。而且其实可以买到很便宜的。对啊。我搬出去的时候就超喜欢。二十多岁时，Facebook二手市场就是你最好的朋友。真的，我跟你说，有很多东西，我要说二十多岁
20s is shopping secondhand. I think we underestimate the value of it and we overestimate the sparkles around brand new. Because like I got it brand new for this price. Yeah. Not me. I'm like this was used three times and I got it for 70% the reach. our price amazing. I think as well we avoid things like our health a lot too.
时值得投资的一点，就是买二手货。我觉得我们低估了它的价值，而高估了全新商品的光环。觉得“因为我是这个价格买的全新”。对吧。我可不这样。我觉得这东西用过三次，而我只花七成价格就买到了，太棒了。我觉得同样地，我们也很少关注健康之类的事情。
I was about to actually say that. Like health is a huge one that I've figured out. I used to go so cheap when I went to my doctors. Like I would only ever go to doctors that were free and I got bad health care. Yeah. Or I like did not take care of myself because I did not want to spend the money. Yep. And that actually caused problems where I was like, oh, so like now I have to like one example
我刚正想这么说。比如健康就是我后来发现的一个重头。我以前看医生总是挑最便宜的。只挑免费的医生，结果看不好病。对啊。或者因为不想花钱而不好好照顾自己。对啊。这就导致了一些问题，比如现在我不得不，举个例子
is with my eyesight. where when I went to uni, I was like, I'm not going to get my eyes to, it's too expensive, it's too expensive, I kept wearing glasses that like weren't working for me. And then three years later, it was like, well, now you need like a particular kind of glass that's going to cost you $200 more. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. There's even like, and we avoid it because we think the price tag is going to be really high.
就是我的视力。上大学时我想着，我才不要去配眼镜，太贵了太贵了，就一直戴着不适合自己的眼镜。结果三年后，变成了，好吧，现在你需要一种特殊的镜片，要多花两百美元。对啊，确实。对啊。甚至还有，我们逃避它是因为觉得价格会非常高。
So for example, like dentistry is something that we really, we really all don't, don't spend money on it. We don't want to spend money on it and we avoid it because I avoided it for like two years. And so I was like, you need to go to. the dentist and I was like I know because she's so good with it. And then I found this dentistry that was called Dental 99. It's like a $99 dentist that you can go and get like a clean and a checkup. And it was and I went and tested it because I was like, I'm not going to recommend this. Yeah. If I haven't gone and you get it. Like a false root canal.
所以比如牙科，这是我们大家真的、真的都不、都不花钱的领域，我们不想花钱，而且会逃避，因为我逃避了大约两年。然后我说，你得去看牙医了，我说我知道，因为她在这方面很有一套。后来我找到了一家叫Dental 99的牙科诊所。大概99美元就能去看牙医洗牙和检查。我去实测了一下，因为我想，我可不会推荐这个。对啊。如果我自己没去过的话。就像一个假根管治疗。
Yeah. Pull out of chains all being like you've got a cavity. And I'm like, yeah. But that was really good. And so making sure that you don't cut corners on the things that really matter. But You don't necessarily need to be going to like, you know, a double bay GP, which is like a very expensive suburb in Australia. You don't need to do that. You can find ways in the middle. Yeah, 100%. I'm finding a consistent doctor.
对啊。一堆连锁店都说你有蛀牙。我说，好吧。但那个真的很不错。所以要确保在真正重要的事情上不走捷径。但你其实没必要去那种，你知道的，双湾全科诊所，那是澳大利亚一个非常昂贵的郊区。你没必要去那种地方。你可以找到中间的平衡点。对啊，百分之百。找一个固定的医生。
I think the other thing is analyzing the things that you, is your cost per wear. So the things that you use every day. So for example, for me, I drink coffee every day. So my coffee machine is like $700, but I think I drink like two coffees a day every day. So it's paid itself back. It is paid itself back. And then some. So those things as well as like winter boots, sneakers, your jeans, kind of those items that, you know, do go through the cycle.
我觉得另一件事是分析你所消费东西的使用成本，也就是你每天都在用的东西。比如对我来说，我每天都喝咖啡。所以我的咖啡机虽然要700美元左右，但我想我每天都喝两杯咖啡。所以它早就回本了。早就回本了。而且还绰绰有余。所以这些东西，还有像冬靴、运动鞋、牛仔裤，基本上就是那些你会经常穿的物品。
I used to be when I was 18 because I didn't know any better. I was such, I didn't even know what fast fashion was. Yeah. Well, it wasn't a thing when we were younger. No, it wasn't a thing. But it wasn't, didn't have a label. No. It was like we had it, but we didn't realize what it was.
我18岁的时候就是这样，因为那时候什么都不懂。我甚至不知道什么是快时尚。对啊。好吧，我们年轻时还没这东西。对，那时候没有这东西。但它不是，也没有这个标签。对。我们当时其实在买，只是没意识到那是什么。
Yeah. And like I think that is down to, you know, a little bit of ignorance and privilege that I just had no idea. but as like I've gotten older like fast fashion and the landfill that comes from companies like Sheen and Zara, yeah, is really grim. But also the quality you get is going to fall apart within a year, which is why I would say like these trend items that do tend to come from, you know, fast fashion. Think about whether you really want it and if you're going to be wearing it in three years time. But if you are going to be wearing in three years time, is it going to last?
对啊。而且我觉得这有点归咎于当时自身的无知和优越感，我根本不知道。但随着我年龄增长，快时尚以及像Sheen和Zara这样的公司带来的垃圾填埋问题，真的非常可怕。而且你买到的质量会在一年内散架，这就是为什么我说，这些潮流单品往往来自，你知道的，快时尚。想想你是不是真的想要它，以及三年后你还会不会穿。但如果你三年后还会穿，它能穿那么久吗？
like is it going to last in the wash? Well it's a big thing of like you said winter boots, jeans, sneakers. Yeah. The one that I've realized recently because obviously I'm going overseas, I will be overseas at the time this episode comes out. It's like a really good winter coat. Yeah. Every year I never talking about these.
比如它经得起清洗吗？这就像你刚才说的冬靴、牛仔裤、运动鞋一样，是个大问题。我最近意识到的一点是，因为我显然要出国，这期节目播出时我已经在国外了。那就是一件非常好的冬大衣。对啊。每年我都从没讨论过这些。
Yeah, yeah. I know. Every year I was like, I'm just going to buy like another cheap winter coat and then it would get freezing. I mean, I was like, no, stop. Let's actually think about this in a future sense and let's save my future self some money so that she doesn't have to replace this.
对啊，对啊。我知道。每年我都觉得自己随便买件便宜的冬大衣就行了，然后就会冷得要命。我是说，不，停下。让我们从未来的角度好好想想，帮未来的自己省点钱，这样她就不用
again next year. Yeah, I think as well remembering that no one really cares about your outfit as much as you do is also really helpful. Yeah. Like no one's going to be like, oh, Cindy Walled at four weeks ago to Cheryl's 27th birthday. No one notices. No one cares as much as we think they do. But to kind of like wrap up my very long winded answer of like this and that and this and that, this and that, I think the best thing you can invest your money on in your 20s is people and experiences. Yeah. The people that you love spending time with and ways to spend time with them. And it never needs to be like, you know, $1,000 flights to go traveling together because realistically not a lot of us can afford that.
明年再去换一件了。对啊，我觉得还要记住，其实没人像你自己那样在意你的穿搭，这也很有帮助。对啊。不会有人觉得，哦，辛迪四周前去雪莉27岁生日派对时穿过这个。没人会注意到。没人像我们想象的那么在意。但总的来说，为了总结我这番长篇大论的回答，我觉得你在二十多岁时最值得投资的金钱是人和经历。对啊。你喜欢和他们共度时光的人，以及与他们共度时光的方式。这从来不需要像，你知道的，去旅行要花1000美元买机票，因为现实中我们没多少人负担得起。
But it can be spending $20 on a bottle of wine and going and watching the sunset together. Yeah. And like those memories don't actually have a price tag on them. Like there are so many moments that I think of with the friends that I have and the people that I love that I, it was never, you know, a lot of money, but those moments and those memories are completely priceless to me. That I think is, well, your 20s, you have a lot of freedom. As we get older, our responsibilities to, you know,
但它可以是花20美元买瓶酒，一起去看日落。对啊。而且这些记忆其实是没有标价的。我有太多这样的时刻，和我的朋友们以及我爱的人们在一起，从来都不是什么，你知道的，很多钱，但那些时刻和那些记忆对我来说是完全无价的。我觉得，在二十多岁时，你有很多自由。随着年龄增长，我们对，你知道的，
maybe partners or careers or potentially kids just get stronger and we have a lot less time to make the memories that we want to make for ourselves. So like your time is actually like the most valuable thing that you own. Yeah. So like making sure that you spend. spend that wisely is probably the best way to spend anything in your 20s. That is such a priceless advice as well. Thank you.
也许是伴侣、事业或潜在的孩子们的责任会加重，我们留给自己去创造想要的回忆的时间就会少得多。所以你的时间其实是你拥有的最宝贵的东西。对啊。所以确保你明智地花掉这些时间，可能是你在二十多岁时把任何东西花在刀刃上的最佳方式。这绝对是无价的建议。谢谢。
She does have some little bits of wisdom. And if you kind of find ways to understand your retail therapy habits, you're overspending habits, your impulsive spending habits, you have that money to give to the things that are really important. Like that item of clothing, that piece of furniture, that like impulse, whatever thing that you've bought, that's not going to outlive. anything, any of the memories that you make right now. So I think that is a beautiful place to wrap things up. Thank you so much for coming on and bringing your wisdom. It's actually given me quite a
她确实有一些小智慧。如果你能找到某种方法来理解你的购物疗法习惯、过度消费习惯、冲动消费习惯，你就会有钱把它们投入到真正重要的事情中。比如那件衣服、那件家具、那个冲动买下的什么东西，都无法超越你现在创造的任何记忆。所以我觉得这是一个完美的收尾。非常感谢你来到这里并带来你的智慧。这其实给了我相当
lot to think about in terms of how I manage my money. I actually don't have a budget. And it's a discussion I've been having with myself of like, let's get ahead of this now. It's hard because I feel like as well, you do the budget and you realize like you, I don't want to know. You're like, oh my God, how much money I've been spending? And it's good. You feel empowered. I'm, I'm terrified. I'm I'm terrified. I'm terrified. I'm terrified to look. Buy yourself a nice,
多的启发，关于我如何管理我的金钱。其实我没有预算。这也是我一直在跟自己讨论的一件事，就是让我们现在就把这事给掌控好。这很难，因为我觉得同样地，你做完预算就会意识到，你，我根本不想知道。你会觉得，天哪，我到底花了多少钱？但这样挺好。你会觉得自己很有掌控力。我很，我很害怕。我很害怕。我很害怕。我很害怕去看。给自己买个好的，
nice bottle of wine. I will. By nice, I mean the two for 30 dollar of squealing pig rosé. I love that one. That's my favorite bit of ice in it. Oh my God. I also put ice in my rosé.
好一点的红酒。我会的。所谓好一点，我是指那种两瓶30美元的Squealing Pig桃红葡萄酒。我超喜欢那个。那是我的最爱，里面还要加点冰。天哪。我也在桃红葡萄酒里加冰。
Yeah. I like a little, plus it's not cold enough. I need the ice in it. Yeah. To really, to really make sure it hits. Yeah.
对啊。我喜欢加一点，而且它不够冰。我需要里面有冰。对啊。才能真正，真正达到那种爽快感。对啊。
And also, whenever I spend like $50 on a bottle of wine, I'm like, this tastes like shit. Oh my God, I did that the other day. And it's not good, is it? I happened. We went out to like this French, me and my, I almost said his name.
而且每次我花50美元买瓶酒，我都觉得：这尝起来像狗屎。天哪，我前几天就干过这事。而且真不好喝，对吧？我碰巧。我和我的，我们去了一家法国，我差点说出他的名字。
Me and my boyfriend went out to like this French bistro. And the cheapest bottle of wine was $60 and it was the worst thing I've ever tasted. I was like, this. I was like, I would rather have drunk like juice or like vinegar than drunk this. Yeah. Anyhow, we got on track. We were on like such a nice little end note. And then I'm like now, wine.
我和我男朋友去了一家法国小酒馆。最便宜的一瓶酒要60美元，结果那是我喝过最难喝的东西。我当时就觉得。我觉得：我宁愿喝果汁或者醋，也不想喝这个。对啊。不管怎样，我们回到正轨。我们刚才聊得那么好，结果现在我又聊到酒了。
Let's talk about alcohol. That's the other thing to invest in your 20s. Good wine. No, opposite of that. No, shit wine. Yeah, shit wine. But again, thank you for coming on. Al is one part of two broke chicks. Sally Sal could not be with us today. But you should absolutely go and listen to their podcast and follow them wherever you would follow anybody. TikTok, Instagram, Twitter. No. No, don't do that. Facebook, actually. I think people, they get enough from us on their other platforms. I'm like, you know what, I'll give you one reprieve. Yes. You don't have to see us there. Yeah, I don't think. like 40 year old men on there
我们来聊聊酒精。这是二十多岁时要投资的另一件事。好酒。不，刚好相反。不，烂酒。对，烂酒。不过再次感谢你来参加节目。Al是Two Broke Chicks的两大主播之一。Sally今天没能和我们一起来。但你们绝对应该去听她们的播客，并在任何地方关注她们。TikTok、Instagram、Twitter。不。不，别去那儿。其实是Facebook。我觉得大家在她们的其他平台上已经看够我们了。我就觉得，你知道吗，我给你们放个假。对。你们不用在那里看到我们。对，我觉得
very interested in what we have to say either. I really don't want to get into that. As soon as I saw Twitter was like majority men, I was like, yeah, pass. Yeah, just don't go in there. It's like a fucking... Just scares me. Hell pit of just terrible opinions.
那上面的40岁大叔们对我们要说的话也毫无兴趣。我真的不想卷入其中。我一看到Twitter上大部分都是男人，我就想：好吧，告辞。对，千万别去那儿。简直就像个他妈的…… 简直让我害怕。一个充斥着糟糕观点的地狱深渊。
Oh, great. Maybe I should join. Yeah, you can add some. Anyhow, yeah, we did it again. Go and find out. I will make sure that all of her links and all of Two Brokechicks links are in the description. And as always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, IHart, wherever you are listening.
哦，太棒了。也许我该加入。对，你可以贡献一些。不管怎样，我们又做到了。去关注吧。我会确保她的所有链接以及Two Broke Chicks的所有链接都在简介里。和往常一样，如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify、iHeart或其他你收听节目的地方留下五星好评。
Make sure you are following along so that you get new episodes in your feed every day. Every day. It's a big promise. Twice a week. Yeah, big changes in the new year, twice a week. And if you have an episode suggestion, as always, my DMs, my inbox is always open to ideas from you guys. So follow me at That Psychology Podcast or at Gemma Spag with the J. to send me a message and have a lovely afternoon morning wherever you are.
确保你点击了关注，这样你的动态里每天都会有新节目。每天。这可是个大承诺。一周两次。对，新年有大变化，一周两次。如果你有节目建议，和往常一样，我的私信、收件箱永远向大家的想法敞开。所以通过Instagram关注我 @That Psychology Podcast 或 @Gemma Spag（Spag带j）给我发消息，祝大家无论身处何地都有一个美好的下午或早晨。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kare Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you've, need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your
嘿，最近怎么样，伙计们？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kare Games主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个节目旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方根本不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你就需要这么做。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲，但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子都炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience. in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即T-W-A-%。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《The Girlfriends》。
Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。